If you lost track of Lou Diamond
Phillips after Longmire ended,
we've tallied up some of the best ways to
catch up with him. Here's what Phillips has
been up to since the acclaimed Wyoming-set
crime drama aired its final episode in 2017.
Even when Lou Diamond Phillips didn't
have a regular TV series, he was still
a familiar face on TV, turning up regularly in
prominent guest star spots in just about every
genre. This hasn't changed since Longmire wrapped.
Phillips has turned up on crime procedurals like
Criminal Minds, and NCIS: New Orleans, as well
as landed a juicy recurring role on Blue Bloods.
And, notably, it's only a recurring role because
of Phillips — he was too good for the show to let
him go after only one episode. As Blue Bloods star
Donnie Wahlberg explained in an interview with Pop
Culture, Phillips' character Louis Delgado was
originally slated to die in his first episode.
But Wahlberg loved working with Phillips too
much for that to happen. He told Pop Culture,
"It's just rare you get to work with somebody
you click with so well and they're amazing at
what they do. I feel like he makes me a better
actor and he makes our show a better show."
Phillips' part on Blue Bloods
was accordingly expanded,
and his character wound up having a rich,
complex connection with Wahlberg's Danny Reagan.
Lou Diamond Phillips has a distinctive voice, and
lately he's been putting it to good use. Since the
Longmire finale in 2017, Phillips has more than
doubled the amount of voice acting on his resume.
On Disney's The Lion Guard, a Lion King spinoff
series, he provided the voice for Surak; he also
had a recurring role on the children's show Elena
of Avalor and did a guest spot on Family Guy.
This is an intriguing new direction for Phillips,
and it's one that makes a lot of
sense. He's always worked hard to
make sure his career was as multifaceted as
possible. In an interview with UPI, he said,
"I literally trace [this versatility] back to
my theater days, which started in high school
and then with my degree from the University
of Texas in Arlington. I did everything."
Notably, voice acting is also an easy
way for him to make appearances on
children's shows like Elena of Avalor.
He told Yahoo Finance that, as a father,
he really appreciates the effort to provide
more diverse children's programming.
After Longmire, if you wanted your regular Lou
Diamond Phillips fix, your best bet was the 2019
crime show Prodigal Son, where he played NYPD
Lieutenant Gil Arroyo. Warm and level-headed,
Arroyo is a kind of natural successor to
Henry Standing Bear. Phillips told UPI,
"The integrity and the moral compass
of Gil Arroyo is very much like that
of Henry [...] but one is a very
rural guy, a Native American,
and the other one is an urban Filipino,
so it's nice to have that latitude."
The role is similar enough that Longmire
fans should check the show out, but still
different enough to be a change of pace for
Phillips. He likes to keep things fresh.
Prodigal Son is a dark crime drama about
an investigator father was a serial killer.
The cases of the week can delve into some extreme
territory, but cast chemistry and sympathetic
characters keep it grounded. While the show was
unfortunately canceled after its second season,
two seasons of Gil Arroyo are
definitely better than none.
While Lou Diamond Phillips actually
did a little directing before Longmire,
the series opened the door for him to do even
more. When he directed Season 6's "Fever," he
clearly caught the directing bug. It's not that
unusual for actors to get the chance to direct
an episode on their own shows, but Phillips
really took the ball and ran with it. He didn't
just take the reins on Longmire and Prodigal
Son, where he was a series regular — he also
directed an episode of Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
as well as an episode of Fear the Walking Dead.
"I feel very honored that they've given
me and trusted me an opportunity to,
you know, tell this story."
It's probably easier, he admitted in
an interview with Nerds and Beyond,
to keep his directing and acting
separate. Phillips told the outlet:
"I've often gotten so caught up in watching
my other actors during a scene that I forget
my own lines. That's why we have multiple takes!"
We can also look forward to seeing more of this
side of Phillips' career.
The actor went on to add:
"I absolutely love directing and consider it
to be simply yet another branch of my creative
tree. [...] I truly enjoy working with the other
artists (cinematographers, production designers,
stunt coordinators, every crew member really)
to take great ideas and actualize them."
Longmire fans who miss Lou Diamond
Phillips can also look for him
in a surprising place: the
bookstore. In October 2020,
he published the young adult science fiction
novel The Tinderbox: Soldier of Indira.
Phillips told Nerds and Beyond that the story
stemmed from the manga-style concept art his wife
had done for a prospective graphic novel. Phillips
started the project off as a screenplay and
"reverse-engineered" the story into a
novel, a project that took 10 years. He
told UPI that 2020 lockdowns gave him the
time he needed to buckle down and finish.
And the results are impressive. The
Nerd Daily reviewed the book, saying,
"Phillips has skillfully woven
together a fantastical story
with realistic touchstones. [....] The plot
is driving, the characters are memorable,
and the writing is satisfying.
Enhanced by the striking drawings,
Phillips has built a world here which readers
will undoubtedly wish to visit again."
They might be in luck. Phillips confirmed with
UPI that a second book is already in the works.
With some novel-writing
experience now under his belt,
we're betting readers won't have
to wait 10 years for this next one.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.